okay let's go to Dante from Florida we
haven't heard from Dante for a while
Dante is last time he called in he was a
Tulsi supporter Dante you still with
Tulsi I'm actually a very sinister but I
do support don't forget Tulsi gabbard's
kennedy but yeah she's still a pretty
progressive candidate
I never expected her to win the
nomination but okay I think you're right
about that um but my question was so it
do you think that there's a possibility
that was a bit world.the Dante you're
breaking up liber8 you've got a bad
connection I heard is there a
possibility that Elizabeth Warren you
know you think that Elizabeth Warren
would be the candidate that the
establishment fully gets behind in the
2019 into 2020 Democrats primary as
opposed to who as opposed to trump or as
opposed to other Democrats are you
saying in the primary or what in the
primary in the primary will the
establishment get by I mean listen they
might have no choice at a certain point
you know listen the Democratic
establishment is not going to vote for
Trump so they are going to push for an
establishment candidate in the primary
it seems to be Biden my my if it's not
Biden the most establishment seeming
people to me strike me as Kamala Harris
and Budaj edge is Warren more
establishment than Bernie yes I guess if
you're gonna put everybody you know kind
of like on a number line
Warren's more establishment than Bernie
but ultimately the establishment is
going to have to figure out how to work
with whoever wins the primary and
support them against Trump yeah but I
was just thinking it'd be this is
seeming more like Annie Elizabeth Warren
than anybody else because Kamala Harris
isn't really going anywhere she's been
stuck in the same spot you're now
talking about who's more likely to win
but I thought you were asking me who the
establishment gonna end up supporting
fully backing because it's not gonna be
Joe Biden it is look like he's going
down in the polls and he's losing
support even from establishment donors
and establishment class and greedy and
all of that
period at a certain point it may become
clear that it's not going to be Biden
and there's not going to be that long
between that point and when the
primaries are decided so there's not
going to be that much time for the
establishment to say oh we're now
shifting this way or that way I think
the establishment candidates are Biden
Harris Buddha judge in that order I
agree with what you're saying it doesn't
look like Harris and Buddha judge are
going anywhere though yeah so that's all
like the entire Democratic leadership
the DNC Nancy Pelosi section because I
like they're just gonna sit back and not
just like try to get influence over
whatever the potential nominee is so it
seems like they're gonna get behind
whoever their best chance to beat Bernie
Sanders that they think would be and it
seems like yeah I mean I think I don't
know that the establishment would be
thrilled for it to be worn instead of
Bernie on policy they end up in almost
identical places Warren comes from a
slightly more establishment Warren than
Bernie though she I mean she's not
really committed to Medicare for all
they she would continue the status quo
foreign policy see Bernie and Warren are
very far apart
what's an issue what's it what's a
difference on foreign policy um she just
hasn't really made it a priority Bernie
Sanders he made it a priority to get
through that the vote to and US
involvement in the war in Yemen
Elizabeth Warren hasn't really made much
of an effort that's not evidence that
they would be substantive the first time
anybody ever had the War Powers invoked
in in the Senate so that is a big thing
and it's a big difference between
Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders so
different but we'll see what happens
dante always great to hear from you my
friend all right
okay good to hear from you I'm glad I'm
glad for you to hear from me as well
alright that's it for today sorry to
everybody I didn't get to we will take a
quick break and be back with plenty more
right after this